bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
momento io sono un famigerato il sito
granny due cene senso avranno fatto il
primo per telefono oggi hanno fatto il 2
perché ha avuto talmente tanto successo
e quindi adesso hanno fatto il 2
facciamolo salve sono sempre contento di
essere il nipote che si sveglia a casa
della nonna stato bella casa aggiungerei
os apre la porta senza che nessuno mi
ammazzi vi prego benissimo allora poi
c'è una scatola ho bisogno di un piede
di porco va bene alla ragazzi credo che
sia spero non sia più difficile
dall'altro granny perché oh mio dio c'è
una scala sono 18 prendo non mi ricordo
come la l'altro grandi ma era molto
inquietante questo che sembra abbastanza
inquietante ma non c'è uscito il polipo
dal frigo perché la casa conduce alle
fogne nelle fogne c'è una barca come è
possibile tutto questo spiega temi vi
prego poco questa roba abili porco o
troppo subito bene qua c'è un lucchetto
della chiave del lucchetto ormai chiaro
no poi anche di porto non lo usiamo i
piedi palco cielo solo per bellezza
perché ovviamente talmente bello
comunque mettiamo c'era un po di
mettiamoci un po di gioco sotto questa
ruggine quando avete voglia un clan ma
la barca non la posso prendere no a
startegia il bisogno del non posso
ancora per far partire da sempre
ovviamente perché serve devo mettere il
motore uno sport plus la gasolina ave
certo manca il gas manca lo spreco un po
come scappare da di da venerdì 13
va bene ragazzi ora andiamo di sciopero
tra due piede di porco innanzitutto e
poi aprire la scatola e questo è già
buono oppure darlo intestata granny che
data ancora non se li stava bene apro
questa roba qua una stanga standard ramo
non ci credo posto sparare grendi subito
subito va bene va benissimo dai la pista
porta e non acciai delle spine
nell'armadio che armadio brutto ma ci
metterei mai nessuno qui dentro tranne
una persona una persona perché attivo
oddio ma gomes caduta non ci credo che
l'ignoto e quindi no persona io ho perso
l'asta ngan e vabbè mi serviva avevano
dai grandi ti puoi spostare che dove
recuperare proiettile non ne posso più
eccolo oggi ora possono usare il nuovo
ma sono fortissimo salve le il nonno
effetti che un regalo per lei ma che
figata cielo chiave il nonno al collo la
prendo subito grazie anche lei un piede
di porco vedo guarda le rubo la chiave
mi scusi no no però non può sopportare
solo un oggetto volta e allora usiamo la
chiave per cosa dove è andato a graham i
ragazzi che l'eni è scomparsa aiuto è
scomparsa granny dove la uso st chiave
aiuto né troppo
mi scusi è troppo grossa per metterla
nel paddock di sotto quindi aprirà
qualcos'altro cos'è questo d'or loc
ma cos'è questo cosa sono sti oggetti
qui vabbè allora prendo la security chi
prendo la chiave del nonno perché
sicuramente aprire a qualcosa ma dov'è
il nonno ma dove sono finiti o ragazzi
cosa presta chiave qui porco demonio
cos'è sta roba
[Applauso]
and what signori ho trovato un posto
segreto in tutto questo ancora non ho
capito definita granny e dov'è finita
grampa però va bene bellissima statua
che ne dite di usarlo ogni tanto
perfetto su tutto ora all anno la
valvola quasi un fucile
mio dio ragazzi tutto c'è la valvola per
aprire la la la barca di sotto o tutto
solo st chiave non ho capito cosa serve
ti prego vennero fucino invece un fucile
veloce non ci arriva sotto delle troppo
alta negrini le sparate sparo ti ammazzo
no ragazzi dovevo assolutamente voi
pochi o ma sta chiave qualcosa dovrà
aprire porca vacca mio dio
ragazzi ho trovato tutto come sei
simpatica potresti fare la youtube
ti devo andare veramente a trovare dove
si cosa proposta chiave ragas però è
sotto di sopra non ci si aggrappa non
c'è grampa però devo aprire apri
qualcosa per favore ci sarà un qualcosa
apre questa chiave maledizione qualsiasi
cosa col demonio
porca vacca vi sono cagato sotto dai
allora se tutto va bene teoricamente gli
oggetti non si dovrebbero essere
spostati se io riuscissi arrivare fin
sopra velocissimo prendere e sia la
gasolina che la valvola posso scappare
18 con la barca al problema che hanno
capito come si apre la porta di sotto ha
capito però ci avevo tutto porca vacca
per una volta nella vita c'avevo tutto
allora cioè di uova stanga ragazzi devo
andare di sopra e prendere la roba per
la gasolina andare di sotto che è quindi
di rampa andato qua se per caso cioè
mila stendo veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce lo faceva per fidata non
c'è granny se mi ascoltate
teoricamente io vorrei fare una roba
ecco granny allora perfetto ora troppo
la roba ok buttala gasolina di sotto mio
dio dove doveva casoli nacua perfetto
prendi la prendi una veloce ok ora devo
trovare tutto di sotto di prendere la
spagna
non perché sono rischio no ti prego
sfiga ma dai sei andato di sopraffare
cosa dai micro c'erano venti stanze di
sopra un po il rischio di sopra ma porca
valcava che difficilissimo ho perso la
stanga ragazzi l'ho buttata per terra
tutto contento invece non è solitamente
a gasolina veloce eccola qua la stanga
n'è rimasta di sopra e mettila di sotto
per cortesia ok quest'anno se torno su o
la pistola gasol in canvas veloce
velocissimo allora devo andare di sotto
a mettere la cosa nella nella della
barca l'uomo è qui no no non ci credo ma
cosa ci fai qua con un ragazzo è
difficilissimo ma cosa ci faceva qui ma
non era qui era di sopra ma dai
almeno cielo davanti porco demonio tre
morti per mettere st fottutissima
gasolina nella barca tre morti che poi
tra l'altro nel suo contenuto e ancora
se non è ancora una poi basta alla
stanga nelle o non essere qui sotto non
essere qui sotto perfetto
prendi sta benedetta gasolina egli è la
metti nella barca nella barca ok nella
barca bene avevo tener premuto
addirittura le meccaniche di gioco
mettiamo molto bene ora manca chi se ne
frega da puntare più manca la levetta
ha risparmiato come va bene manca la
levetta l'ala la manopola per girare la
barca che si trova sempre di sopra
ora vado di sopra e prendo la stanga
non prendo la stanga ne entra dentro
entra dentro entra dentro chiudi la
porta veloce cliccati sotto non mi vede
non mi vede perché cesare un letto cioè
nella stanza dove sarò mai sarà acceso
di sotto la risposta è sì perfetto
saliti che si stupì devo raggiungere
solo la stanga così a me non posso
difendermi e allo stesso tempo andare di
sopra e prendere la manopola che la
stanganelli la standiana prendiamo
prendi la prendi la prima prima veloce
veloce ok ora il primo tizio che mi si
para davanti perfetto cori aspetta
aspetta per il colpo prendi colpo il
colpo per terra prendi no non riesco a
prendere i colpi per terra sogna il
colpo non riesco a prendere il colpo per
terra non c'è
mio dio che fastidio
un colpo per terra un'ora un'ora e mezza
di colpo un'ora e mezza va bene bene se
vedo il nonno perfetto era quello che
volevo fare
riprendi il colpo benissimo ho di nuovo
la stanga né adesso vediamo cosa c'è di
sopra perché teoricamente il nonno prima
che le spari ci mette due minuti e
granny se mi si avvicina le sparo quindi
qua ok qua non ho capito cosa serve devo
ancora a perlustrare per bene sto piano
ragazzi ancora non ho visto questo a
security chi vedi che cosa prima quella
maledettissima chiave questa è la
manopola a noi con questo per il fucile
ottimo vado ad aprire la cassaforte di
sotto ma per aprirla devo prima stendere
la nonna di fisso proprio
vedi la chiave vedi la chiave di prima e
questa security chi prendi la prendi lay
up di questa porta qua maledizione
ok sono riuscito non so cosa c'è qua
dentro una telecamera di sorveglianza
non è vero
no c'è una sede una telecamera
maledizione
ho capito che la chiave del
dell'armadietto della cassaforte era di
sopra
l'uomo inviato nell'armadio no no no no
no no no no non fare non toccare il
tasto questa era per voi non è per me
non schiaccia bello il fatto che ci sia
la stanga credo che farò un secondo
episodio sicuramente perché devo provare
a vedere se riesco a battervi secondo me
ce la posso fare ragazzi mi ci devo
impegnare ma secondo me ce la faccio
forse episodio ti assicuro che ci provo
per adesso con quello che i ragazzi cosa
inserire sul documento me mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciatela
campanellina prima della giocatrice
video che escano e noi come sempre ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo il telo ragazzi
[Musica]